Father's Day is about a week away and
like a lot of people I'm not gonna be
able to see my dad this year he's in New
Jersey and I'm in Texas so I decided I
would try to build him something that's
easy to share digitally a
machine-learning powered searchable
video archive and at the end of this
episode I will share with him and we'll
see what he thinks of it
[Music]
my dad has definitely always been the
primary video man my dad's first video
was the day that I was born so he has
his camera on me in the bassinet and I'm
looking very red and gooey and then my
mom is has just given birth and it's
amazing that she allowed herself to be
on camera
and since then he's just been taking
tons and tons of video so a couple of
years ago my dad uploaded all of our
family footage to Google Drive so I
decided to build my dad an AI powered
video archive which would allow us to
actually search through all the videos
and find the most interesting bits here
is the searchable video archive that I
had a building that allows you to search
texts and transcripts and objects by
term let's take a look at how I built it
the first step of this project was to
transfer all of my dad's videos from
Google Drive to cloud storage this way
they'd be accessible to the rest of my
GCP project if you're using a files on
your desktop you can just upload them
directly from within the UI but if
you're transferring files from Google
Drive check out my blog to see the hack
I use to make uploading much faster next
I analyze all those videos using the
video intelligence API which is the main
AI workhorse at the center of this
project this tool takes the video as
input and it spits out lots of different
annotations like what's actually going
on in an image is it a wedding is it
fireworks a cute dog it uses computer
vision detect objects and events in
videos
it also transcribes the audio track from
videos so we can later search by what
people say this is how I was able to
search for my very first steps that's
their walking
this is the first time she's taking
major steps on this floor it can also
grab text shown on screen so you can
search for things written on t-shirts or
posters or on signs or on birthday cakes
this is how I found my first birthday I
also use this feature to grab the time
stamps that appeared on screen in some
of my dad's older videos once I
extracted all of these searchable
features I could use them to quickly
search through those videos now using
the video intelligence API is pretty
straightforward you just import the
video intelligence library and call the
analyze video function passing a path to
the location of restored video in cloud
storage now because my video files were
massive I tried to do all of this
processing exclusively in the cloud
because downloading things onto my
desktop would have been really slow I
chose an architecture that looked like
this first like I showed you earlier I
uploaded my videos to a cloud storage
bucket which is like a folder in the
cloud I used uploading a video to
trigger a cloud function in that cloud
function I called the video intelligence
API which analyzed the uploaded video
and wrote the data to firestore finally
I needed a way to quickly sort through
all of this data so for this I used a
handy non-google tool built by a company
called algo Lea it's a search tool that
lets you upload json and then offers an
api to search through it quickly it
handles things like correcting for typos
and finding the most relevant results so
that was pretty much how I built the
backend to build a front-end or a user
interface I decided to learn how to use
flutter which is a Google framework for
building apps and I built a flutter web
app which looks like this of course
there are tons of ways you could build a
front end without flutter using
JavaScript or for iOS or Android your
choice and that's it in a nutshell if
you want to learn more about the
technical details of this project or to
see the code make sure you check out my
blog post linked in the description
below alright I guess it's time to show
this app to a real user let's show it to
my dad so dad I built something for you
for Father's Day and I'm really excited
and also really nervous to show you oh
it's probably the most high effort
Father's Day gift I've ever worked on
I'll look at all this I see scooter and
Monticello so I think I know where this
is going oh wow look at all this Wow
I know all these pictures so I took all
of your video in Drive and I analyzed it
with machine learning so that first of
all I split all of your really long to
our clips into little chunks and I made
them searchable so in addition to these
ones Father's Day in performance you can
search by anything that you want that's
interesting so can I search for let's
say we used to play ping pong
you think the ping pong table might show
up try it
[Music]
oh look at that there it is
I remember when I first when we bought
your first bicycle how excited you are
so how about wait this look at the
inherent this is what I was looking for
this isn't this video right here but it
brought all these other bicycles in as
well our need every one of these
pictures has the bike in it but this is
the specific one that I was looking at
so yeah it would have definitely found
it very neat so it you really can be
very loose with your search terms here
you know I guess the looser it is the
more likely your to find him that you
can just zoom in I guess you can get
specific if there's a lot of occurrences
this is very nice thank you very much
for the all the to be early Father's Day
gift I can't wait to show mommy of
course that's all I wanted to show you
thanks for filming with us okay so how
do you need me to end this I have I have
an idea of an idea can you search for
fade out oh yeah I said that all the
time I think at the end of every video
we said that lets say if I let's see how
long this one is okay I'm gonna fade out
[ __ ] we're not you sure you show it
outgoing goodbye
[Music]
you